I'm going to give you a glimpse as to why it works.
Suppose we have two robot positions, x0 and x1, and we know they're 10 apart
with some Gaussian noise, and we know the Gaussian noise in exportation
moves the right robot position 10 off the left robot position, but there is some uncertainty.
When we talked about Kalman filters, we talked about Gaussians,
and this uncertainty might look at follows:
There is a constant exponential, and the expression that x1 minus x0
should relax to 10 but might deviate from it.
This Gaussian constraint over here characterizes the constraint between x1 and x0
and wishes them to be exactly 10 apart.
The Gaussian is maximum where this equation is fulfilled,
but if the residual is not equal to 0, there is still a probability associated with it.
Let's now model a second motion. Say x2 is 5 apart.
We now get an even bigger Gaussian relative to the very first one,
but the local constraint over here reads just like the constraint over there.
Let me just write it down.
X2 minus x1 minus 5 squared over sigma-squared.
Now, the total probability of this entire thing over here is the product of these two things.
If we want to maximize the product, we can play a number of interesting tricks.
First, the constant has no bearing on the maximum, just on the absolute value.
If we want to find the best values for x0 and x1 and so on, we can drop the constant.
Secondly, we can drop the exponential
if we're willing to turn the product into an addition.
Remember, we added things in omega and in sigma. That's why.
Finally, we can actually drop the -1/2.
It turns out that also plays no role in the maximization of this expression.
It turns out what you added where constraints just like these,
and you even added them at a certain strength of 1 over sigma-squared.
In particular, if you really believe that a constraint is true,
you should add a larger value in this matrix over here,
and on the right side you should multiply the right constraint with an even larger value.
Put differently, take an expression like this and multiply in the sigma-squared
you get something of this nature over here where 1 over sigma
regulates how confident you are.
For a small sigma, 1 over sigma becomes large.
So 5 is much larger than 1.
That means you have much more confidence.
Let's go back to the code and modify the code
so the last measurement has a really high confidence.
I want you to multiply the last measurement between x2 and our landmark
with a factor of 5 in your code. Hard code it.
That is, go in somewhere over here where the last measurement is being applied
and do the trick that I just showed you and see what the outcome is.
When I do this, I get -3, 2.1, 5.714, and 6.821 as the answers.
You'll see in this final result
the final robot position of 5.714 and the landmark position of 8.821
are really close to 1 in difference, which was the measurement,
because you know believe this measurement
over-proportionally over other measurements and motions.